عمليات الاجلاء كانت قد وصلت الى ذروتها
بعد ان اغسطس الماضي ما رايناها خلال
زيارتنا الى مدينه بخمود مع زميل رجيمز
اندرياشي بحزم الصعوبات التي يعيشها من
بقي في المدينه رفقنا ثنائي كان يحاول
الخروج وحاولنا ان نفهم كيف تتم هذه
العمليات اولا عبر مبادرات شخصيه وعبره
متطوعين باتوا يقومون بما يشبه تنظيم
دوريات لمحاوله خروج شاحنه او حافله مخصصه
من المدينه هناك الرقم مطبوع على احد
الجدران يجب الاتصال به لكن كما نعلم
الاتصالات مقطوعه في مدينه بخموت ويوجد
انتظار الفرصه الثانيه حديث ذلك اولا
ثانيا عندما تحدثنا مع سائق الحافله قال
انه اضطر مثلا الى الغاء احد الرحلات بعد
مو ضرب جسر كان يسلكه لي الوصول الى
المدينه ما جعل الطريقه تغرق في المياه
ولم تعد حافلاته قادره على الوصول الى
المدينه باي حال من بقي في المدينه هم
الاشخاص اولا اما من كبار همم العمر وغير
القادرين على تحمل مشقه السفر هناك بالطبع
جزء بقي طوعا لن ننسى انه في المدن في شرق
اوكرانيا هناك ايضا جزء من الناس
المواليين للجانب الروسي لكن لا يسرحون
بذلك فمن الان ولكن عندما نتحدث عن مخموت
نتحدث ايضا عن هروب من القصف الذي يستمر
المعارك المدفعيه حاضره على مدار الدقيقه
وبالتالي عندما نتحدث عن خروج من المدينه
هو بدايته خروج من دائره الخطر بغض النظر
عن الاراء الايديولوجيه همم في همم
المدينه ثم معظم المدنيين والاطفال تم وهم
هذه المدينه بلا تدفئه بلا غاز بلا شبكه
انترنت بلا شبكه هاتف
واثناء دخولنا خلال اليومين الماضيين كانت
بعض الضربات المدفعيه تصيب اهدافا داخل
المدينه بعينها وبعض المبادرات الشخصيه من
المتطوعين تقوم على همم اعطاء ومحاوله
مساعدات كبار العمر الذين باتوا داخل
المدينه لوحدهم